Ichi is out there there just has to be
in that hundred million star system
galaxy that we belong we are we part in
we dwell in other cases of life
originating because we now know there
are so many planets that sir almost
certain are you're going to have certain
some of the planets that are Goldilocks
that is the right position that next
nearest their Sun the right size and so
on that can have the potential to create
life and of those it seems and we don't
have any basis for this except intuition
that given enough millions of years in
our case we had half a billion years
since life came on the land to produce a
human grade you social species and so we
can only guess that it's likely that
that has occurred in some of them so
here's what I did in the course of this
book actually it I I did it with some
care the meaning of human existence I
looked over the many examples of the
origin of whole new lines of animals
that have occurred on the land since the
early Paleozoic now we're talking going
back more than four hundred and fifteen
million years it's a long time the land
of earth was populated by the first
plants then forests and with them whole
array of animal types we have the many
many multiple lines of animals that
originated and here and we can I think
reasonably conclude
that eusociality when it did develop
including big animals that have the
capacity to create a big brain cerebrum
memory storage areas essentially what it
is and this bizarre round head shape
that we have I mean seen from the point
of view of gorillas who haven't bizarre
funny-looking head that here is what
they all have in common now I'm talking
empirical information first have to be
on the limb can't develop advanced
societies and anything likes of a
civilization which in humans goes back a
couple hundred thousand years well why
not
why no marine freshwater creatures
because they don't have fire you just
have to have in order to build tools
beyond chipping some rock or stone away
or maybe crude binding of a fascist
fashion of materials together you don't
have any way to create more advanced
technology without concentrated power
source that you can transport from one
place to another et and now drawing this
again from the record of multiple
origins of animal lines on earth et has
got a head and the heads up front and
the head continues the central
organizing centers for all of the senses
they're spread out through the body
et it's got a small number of limbs
multiple maybe six
who knows maybe eight like us like a
spider ah but not that many
a relatively few and et has on these
limbs fingers or
or tentacle something with strength and
flexibility that are free
you see that's what that was a
prerequisite than we had when we steps
out of the trees our ancestors did five
million years years or so ago the
earliest known Austral pist pre-human
already was walking on hind leg that was
just an adaptation it had and one of the
consequences of freeing the front legs
is that now you have organs that can be
modified to manipulate but there's more
and that is you have to have soft pulpy
fingertips and when you think about it
think about the primates you know old
world and new world that's a primate
trait soft pulpy fingertips because you
need those to manipulate finally in the
in our ancestors case and all the
primates that are arboreal and so on you
need to be able to manipulate pits of
food you know like plucking free a piece
of fruit plucking seeds out of a fruit
taking a flower and opening it and
eating it and so on arm so that's that's
another trait of ET and I would admonish
scriptwriters for Hollywood films that
have space and alien monsters invading
Earth
don't give them Claus a Claus or for
carnivores and Karan you've got to be an
omnivore to be a nietzsche there just
isn't enough energy available and in the
next trophic level down to maintain big
populations and stable populations that
can evolve civilization that was a bit
of a stretch but I feel confident about
that clause or no for that's for
carnivores ET is big not big elephant
size
for gravity you know if you have a very
light of gravity in a small molar planet
or you would be able to get a gigantic
animal that's very mobile for earth
planet Earth size an elephant is just
too big to really get anywhere a primate
is just the right size this is the sort
of the Goldilocks rule for size so those
are some of the traits of ET and to that
I'll add in addition they're being
omnivore that they will be they will
have moral instincts that is they will
be able to be generous to at least some
extent caring and altruistic
not just to individuals of their own
species but to other species and there's
a reason I say that and that is because
almost certainly all of the youth social
creatures that produce advanced
societies did so through group selection
group versus group when you have groups
competing with groups and driving
helping drive a social instinct
instincts by this Darwinian superiority
of cooperation within the group then you
have the capacity for a moral system
within a group and then eventually
between groups under certain
circumstances but not nearly as strong
between groups as it is within groups
that I think is a statement of the
prevailing theory of the origin of
morality in human beings and I'll close
this with a mantra that's useful and
that is as follows within a group
selfish individuals beat
altruistic individual if you have both
you know genetic propensity those who
have a genetic propensity towards
selfishness versus those that have
capacity for altruism and more
cooperative behavior within the group
the selfish ones prevail over the
altruistic ones but in competition
between groups which is absolutely
intense in all you social species
including humans and that group
competition is what defines humans to a
large extent between groups the
competition is such that how groups of
altruist defeat groups of self
individuals so you get a kind of a
balance always in human evolution
between a tendency to be increasingly
altruistic and cooperative cooperative
balance of some extent by a tendency of
individuals in these groups to perform
behave in a selfish manner with respect
to others and we better balance in human
beings and it's unstable it can never
come to some point like a Nash
equilibrium and stomp but it means that
we're always going this is you this is
the nature of humans that we are
eternally internally eternally
conflicted in our thinking in our
self-examination and our decisions we're
making and that's a good thing that it's
unstable that it's a product of these
this great fundamental conflict because
that's a source of human creativity in
the creative arts and competitive
behavior among people in between groups
that drives a lot of the best salience
of the evolution of civilization
you